what's going on guys
GI Joe retaliation is in theaters now
we saw it and we're going to talk about
it with two of the people you'd want to
hear talk about it most very special
guests with us today introduce
yourselves
I am Cobra Commander resident of Cobra
Eggland's and this is my personal
assistant Cobra PR of PR relations you
don't want me to use your real names no
you're using them yeah we're staying in
character the whole time you spoke to
our offices and said you wanted Cobra
Commander you got the real deal right
yeah I mean so what have you been up to
lately
Cobra Commander we are on a goodwill
tour because American cinema is at it
again trying to make Cobra out to be the
bad guys I mean 20 years later and they
can't let it go I mean what a comic book
came out that's a classy looking guy
everything worked out then the cartoon
game and I'm just a screaming idiot you
have 24 hours let's talk about the
recent films The Rise of Cobra was the
first one damn bad you ever get that
distinct notion that you are hearing the
bat missing the ball we need to find out
everything we can about her knowing is
half the battle you didn't like Joseph
gordon-levitt's portrayal of you you
can't really call it a portrayal it was
just because it wasn't the commander in
any sense of the word
commander I mean this is Cobra Commander
what you saw in the movie that said it
was go-to commander did it look like
this
Cobra Commander as the Baroness's
brother I you were sitting next to her
when you saw that movie right no it
looks on her face it got to the point
where you just had to laugh at it so we
can all agree the Rise of Cobra was a
steaming pile I'm not gonna disagree now
we have GI Joe retaliation whoever did
this will be back we're all that's left
we saw it the other night destro not a
major part of this movie I don't know
not whatsoever how's the relationship
between you and destro I'm pretty good I
mean you know like any long-term
relationship in turn a professional
level let's not start any other rumors
oh let me ask you everyone wants to know
this Cobra Commander are you gay I can
confirm without a shadow of the doubt
the commander is not gay I was very
attracted to their depiction of the
commander it was horrendously terrible
and had no truth in it but that outfit
was I love this beautiful from you it is
a beautiful uniform adjustability are
you saying the official statement from
Cobra PR is that Cobra Commander looked
pretty baller and GI Joe retaliation is
he using lingo with this like a American
vernacular I think so do you have
hip-hop on Cobra Island obviously lately
I've been getting back into Yacht rock
there's just something about Loggins and
doobie brothers it just makes it work
did you find it weird that the wu-tang
clan's RZA was a blind sensei in the
movie I found many things strange in the
movie that we're talking about Snake
Eyes is real sensei also makes
ridiculous beats well you know the thing
about ninjas in general is they're
really good at keeping secrets
you said ninja yes okay good
wanted to make sure that you're not
horribly racist one final question about
the movie how many Cobra symbols would
you give it on a scale of one to five
we'll give it to I enjoyed the
commander's outfit yes yes I get it do
you guys ever do it in these costumes do
it oh no no no no no no no you're gross
no commander a bit of a prude
have you ever had a three-way with the
Baroness Wow here we go again
not appropriate do you ever give a HJ to
the guy that drives the water moccasin
dear God has anyone ever played with
your Wang while you flew in a fang oh my
gosh it even rhymes this is rich oh my
god give me another one ever uh have you
ever taken a piss inside of a hiss oh
wait yeah I did that one time I want to
thank you guys and I would say the
movies better than the first GI Joe
movie not as good as the old cartoon
show I'd agree with poker commander
though and give it two and a half over
cymbals now thank you very much for all
the humorous interview questions you
kill me and I'm pretty sure the PR is
gonna kill you is there an 80s or 90s
cartoon or toy that you would like to
see turned into a major motion picture
leave us an answer in the comment
section below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt want to thank you guys for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye
[Music]